好啊，灵感先说到这儿。
但其实灵感有很多要说的，灵感啊。
我刚才教给大家的只是。
呃。
学习训练积累的方法。
有了这个方法以后呢，大家慢慢去在那个小本上慢慢记。
慢慢去观察，慢慢去体会，去发掘，然后记下来时间长了以后会有一个什么作用呢？会破除你跟灵感之间的距离感。
以前大家说到灵感，都会觉得哎呀灵感好遥远啊。好，这个这个词跟我们跟我们生活没有关系。
我就是告诉你，他没有那么神秘，所谓的灵感就是你的体会。
你的观察。
或者你在那一瞬间的一种感受都是来自于你，来自于你的你跟艺术家的唯一的区别就是艺术家把它记下来了。
你以前为什么没记呢？是为没有这个必要。
从现在开始，这就是你最重要的一个素材库。
这个小本我敢跟你说，是你未来创作中最重要的一个素材。
不管是你从别的片子里面看到的，还是从你自己从自己最内心发现的，还是在你生活中观察的，全都记下来。
好吗？然后有了这些。
这就是灵感。有了这些所谓的灵感以后。
我们。
就可以开始创造故事了。故事我们今天说的故事是可以成为剧本的故事。我们在这里说一下故事。
我们肢解一下这个故事，可以成为剧本的故事，一般分三个要素。
人物。
事件。
主题。
人物事件主题。当然有些书上会写会写事件人物主题。
这个区别不大。
啥区别呢？就是先有鸡还是先有蛋的区别。
一般来说啊啊这个你以后会会想明白这个事儿的，以后在你实操中，你会想明白这个事儿，你会有自己属于自己的见解。我认为呢呃在我实际的工作中，如果我构思电视剧，我会先考虑人。
如果我构思电影，我会先考虑。
出了个什么事儿？
然后人物事件主题就是构成剧本故事的三要素，听着有点像中学生作文课，事件地事件地点人物是吧？看着很简单，但其实啊人物事件主题都很重要，特别是这个主题有很多人不太理解，我觉得啊哎呀中心思想嘛？鲁迅这句话什么意思？你。
是想搞这一套吗？
主题是你这个故事的价值观。
我告诉你非常的重要。
非常的重要。
这不是那个那个语文课里面让你填一下这段话的意义，不是那么呃那个东西啊，是价值观。我们来分别来说一下。
人物。
故事中三要素里面的人物指的是这个故事的主角。
啥叫主角？
什么叫一个故事？主角？
定义上说啊，主角是这个故事的推动者。
只有有行动力的那个角色，是这个。
事件的。
主要是。
听一听很容易。但其实有些戏里面你会就你就会觉得哎人物过多。
这个不太好，就一个故事，有些故事里面涉及到多个人物，你有时候会乱。我告诉你主角怎么去理解？
就是视角人物。
啥叫视角人物还不好理解。
就是你看这个故事的时候，或者观众看这个故事的时候，观众希望谁成事儿。
观众希望谁成事，观众站在谁那头。
谁就是主角？
用咱们之前第一节课说过的那个术语说，就是观众跟谁有共情。
这样明白了吧？这个人就是主角。
咱们在这个举例的线性故事里面啊，咱们现在讲这个故事，讲讲这个线性故事里面，我们先暂定就一个主角，好吧，不去搞乱事件啊，这个好理解了，就是你这个故事。
主要发生了个什么事儿，主要解决了个什么问题。
主题。
就是你这个。
故事。
体现了价值观。
体现了作者的价值观。
在这里我再强调一下这个价值观非常重要。为什么这个价值观一定要使正能量？
要是正得量。
我跟你们说。
这三个字一写出来，很多人会抢，老师，你是不是党员啊，你怎么突然给我们讲这个。
我告诉你们，我在刚入行的时候也特别叛逆。
我也老有一股不服劲的精神，我会想哎，哎。
一个故事凭什么一定要正能量？
能量是宇宙动，宇宙存在的能量，它就有正的，有负的，有斜的，有横的对吧？每一种能量都有各自的精彩嘛。我当时也是这么想的，但是后来我发现啊。
不是这么理解的不是这么理解的这个正能量正能量这个价值观。我给你们举个例子啊。
比如说。
主角。
假设啊。
是那个那个那个那个一个大侠，一个侠客，对吧？
一个哎大侠的侠怎么写？
哎，不管了啊，一个侠客。
那个他与那个有个什么事儿呢？报仇。
比较容易理解是吧？报仇。
最后。
那体现一个什么主题呢？
比如说他报酬。
他要去办的这个人跟他有私仇。
就是说对于他来说是个坏人。
但是比如说对于一个国家或者民族来说。
那可能是个英雄。
或者是个忠臣。
然后他放弃了报酬。
那是什么意思呢？
就是最后的价值观就是。
就是就是这个丝绸。
这个小鱼。
这个这个大意对吧？这就是体现出来的价值观。他放下了他放下了这丑这个仇恨。
呃，原谅了别人，也解脱了自己。
就是正能量。
正能量。
每一个故事都需要是正能量。
否则观众会在主题上费解，因为为什么？因为这个价值观你这个主题啊，你最后不是喊出来的。
你是这个这个这个这个这个主角做出来的。
那关于这个正能量，我待会儿再细个那细再细说好吧，我们接着往下说。
主角。
也就是这个人物。
啊，我们接着往下看啊。
人物。
我们说这三个要素，我们把它细细分一下，看看会出现什么样的效果。
我们说这个侠客，比如说还是这个侠客，你光说一个侠客啊，有点担保了。
人物。
又可以拆分成三个要素。
身份。
吃粉。
咱们说。
他身份不就是个侠客吗？
不是。
身份是戏种的身份。
故事中的身份侠客是他的职业，是他的标签呃，当然他的标签的职业有可能成为。
他在故事中的。
呃税份。
但是在这个故事中，他的身份。
这个故事是什么呢？
故事是报酬。
他给谁报仇？
替父报酬。比如说。
那其实他的身份是个。
这个儿子。
或者说是一个。
孝子。
明白吗？
所以说这个身份大家必须理解，不是说我今天写一个木匠的故事，所以我这个主角。
呃的身份是个木匠。你如果故事是关于。
他怎么样做好一个木匠活，那他的身份，你这个主角的身份是木匠。
明白吗？
否则的话，这个身份是是是在是他在。
世界。
中的。
角色。
这个一定要搞清楚，好吧，这是人物的身份。
人物的第二个属性。
欲望。
啥叫欲网？
他的这个。
事件中的欲望。
这个事件中的欲望很明确。
他想干嘛？
想报仇。
想报酬。
就是这在这个时件中的欲望，我怎么又给写上去了？
就是他在他在本事件中。
他想得到什么？
我们这么理解吧，好吧。
其实就是他的want。
对吧。
现在有这几年有有有有一套want和ne的理论也比较流行。这个咱们回头再说。
人物的身份，人物的欲望，那与欲望紧接的是动作。
动作是什么？
是他为了满足欲望而付出的行动。
在这个故事当中。
我我们大概能估计出来他的动作就是。
到处找那个仇人要杀掉对方，对吧？就是杀人这个动作。所以。
在这个人物三要素里面，动动作的定义是为为达到欲望而付出的行动。
所以我们一直讲主角要有行动力，要有主动力，动作在这儿。
所以构成人物的三要素身份欲望动作，好吧。
来嗯下一个是。
世件。
对吧。
事件也有三要素。事件的三要素啊。
核心问题。
上海。
结果。
就说你在故事里面，你这个事儿要有这三个要素，核心问题是什么？
障碍是什么？
结果是什么？
核心问题在这个事件中。
的核心问题，那就是想着杀了他。
对吧就是关于杀了他这个事儿是核心问题，肯定不是那么好杀的吧。
为啥有障碍？第一这个人可能不好找。
第二，要杀他之前得杀各种呃小喽啰，对吧？第三呢，找到这个人了，小喽啰也杀光了，这个人武艺高强。
所以你做成这个解决这个核心问题会有各种各样的障碍。
没有障碍的故事，不是精彩的故事。所以有很多人说，对于一个故事来说，最重要的是障碍。
那个。
呃，书上翻译成沟壑。
咱们要记得，以后看到沟壑这个词儿也不要觉得陌生，那个壑很难写，所以我写了阻碍，然后写还写了障碍，还有翻译成阻力，好吧。
结果就是他解决这个核心问题。最后。
得到了一个什么结果，这个很容易理解。
然后。
主题。
主题分两部分啊。
价值观分正价值。
和附加值。
我们说。
我们希望主题是正能量，但是一定会有一个负能量与之相差相对应。这两个能量在这个故事中一定要做对抗的，一定要去做抉择的。就以我们说的这个报酬为例。
就以我们随便说的就是刚才随便说的例子啊，就说这个报酬为例，他最后呃还是那个结局，就是说他的丝绸。
是要杀了这个人，但是他们他又发现这个人通过一直在找他，他又发现这个人。
除了杀了自己的父亲以外。
在其他方面是民族英雄国家栋梁。
对吧？
那么他就会出现正负价值的对抗。
也不也不是那么快就放弃的，肯定要对抗对抗的对吧？正负价值的对抗。
最后一定要是正价值战胜负价值。我说的是95%以上的。
线性故事，写成剧本的线性故事。好吧，你非要跟我说老无所依啊，或者是什么，最后呃很幻面。
那个是另外一种价值，那个不在我们讨论之列。
所以你看啊。
我们说故事分三要素。
人物事件主题人物分3块，事件分3块，主题分正负。
8个东西。
我们说哎呦这个。
咱们前面上课。
相处的挺愉快的，一直都很开心。为什么这一节突然来了这么多概念，你想搞什么对吧？头很大，我告诉你想搞什么这8个元素，我们把它连在一块看一看。
一个什么样的人？
他产生了一个什么样的想法？
为了这个想法，他采取了什么样的行动？
采取这个行动是想解决什么样的问题？解决问题的过程中遇到了很多的障碍。
在这些障碍的阻挠下，最后有一个什么样的结果？这个结果体现了一个什么样的正价值？
这就是一个。
你以后所有的故事。
或者是你上手，你从事你的创作生涯，上手的前十个故事至少。
都要这么跟我讲。
都要这么讲。
你没有能力跳出这个框。
没有能力跳出这个框。
当然你说哎呀，老师，你这个说的有点太夸张了吧。
对吧这个这个这个哪有这个所有的故事难道都是这个框吗？
目前来说都是。
比如说我们随便举个例子啊。
我也不知道大家都看过什么电影，都爱看什么电影。
就比较。
呃，经典的。
我们说周星驰。
喜剧之王大家都觉得啊商业性艺术性都很都很到位，然后又又又特别有意义。我们来看看周星驰。
我们就来卡这8g。
中心在戏中是什么身份？
什么身份？
演员。
群众演员确切的说，群众演员。
我往这边写，好吧。
周星驰的戏中的身份群演。
他的欲望是什么？
出人头地。
对不对？
他的欲望就是出人头地，他做梦都想出人头地。
因为他有一。
我们说一个电影在前25分钟一定会点题。
一定会点题。
他他说。
人如果没有梦想，跟一条咸鱼有什么区别？
所以你。
你说他的欲望是什么？
梦想。
出人头地对吧？梦想具具体就是出人头地。
那他为了这个梦想，他采取了什么样的动作呢？
去剧组去剧组蹭戏，对吧？他天天跑组，我们这种行为叫跑组，跑组蹭戏。
那。
人物说完了。
身份欲望动作。
事件是什么呢？
世界是一次次与机会擦肩而过。
就是机会。
就好难找到机会。
对吧。
他的核心问题就是机会太难找了。
好不容易让他演一次神父，让他死一下，他就死怎么死也死不掉。
因为你给搞砸了，对吧？
而且后面还好像还混碰到了一次这个这个当男一号的机会，但又黄了。
就是。
机会难难寻。
对吧。
机会难觅。
阻碍我们说一我们说一个故事中，阻碍是有人说阻碍是最最重要的。所以阻碍一般来说都是组合型的，好多个阻碍大阻碍小阻碍上来的阻碍是什么？上来阻碍是那个狭义。
是吧这副导演后来还有一个揪他头发的副导演，然后还有要砍他手的吴孟达。
还有社区各种各样给他捣乱的人。
还有那个那个那个黑社会大哥叫什么，对吧？那个那个我忘了叫什么了。
再有那个呃导演投资人。
各种各样的障碍。
形形色色的障碍。
对吧各种艰难，最后的结果是什么呢？
结果是，虽然没有当成明星。
虽然没有当成明星，跑组失败了，但是不耽误他出人头地，成为一个有价值的人。最后的结果就是。
当一个平凡人。
也可以出人头地。
不做明星。
也可以实现梦想。
所以最后的价值其实是什么呢？就是平凡人也可以比明星更有价值。
体会到我说为什么主题都要正能量吗？如果这个故事不去讲，我们不去讲。
这个故事。
也不说这个戏是喜剧之王，也别提周星驰，就说哎我给你讲一个故事，故事呢说的是平凡人也可以有梦想，甚至比做明星还有价值，你肯定不要听。
对吧你肯定不要听。
但是他就藏在这个戏里。
是必须要有的。
是必须要有的。所以我再重头给大家捋一遍好吗？通过这个例子，你大概明白。
这个这个故事的八要素了吧。
我们可以再再举一个例子啊，咱们中国的戏啊这就很少有所有人都看过的。你你说比如说这个这个个这个这个人在囧途也好，心花怒放也好，这种很牛逼的电影也不是所有人都看过。咱们说个耳耳熟能详的西游记。
西游记好不好？西游记所有人都看过来人物是谁告诉我。
有人说是悟空，有人说那取经那老大是唐僧的。
是谁？
主角是谁？
师徒4人。
我告诉你为什么是师徒自人。
因为师徒四人在这种戏里面，你看起来他是个群戏，但其实这师徒四人是一个人。
是一个人，他代表一个人不同的性格，有很多这样的戏。我告诉大家，有很多这样的戏看起来是多男主呃多主角或者是双主角，但其实是一个人。
他代表。
它可以代表一个人两种选择，两种价值或者是不同的性格。在这里就典型的。
代表的。
取经人。
的四种不同性格，不同状态。
所以他其实是一个主角。
我不想在这里讲的过早啊，但我可以给大家透露一句，万一大家在座的有有悟性比较高的啊，你判断一个戏啊，说他真的是一个多主角的戏，还是是一个假多主角的戏。假多主角就是这几个主角其实可你捏在一块儿的，他就是一个人。
就比如说那个那个那个疯狂的外星人，沈腾黄渤那就是一个人，懂吗？
他们俩是一个人。
黄博生，我要刷猴，只能说咱得挣钱。
对吧。
呃，剪了个猴。
捡了那个外星人，黄渤说，我要训他。
沈腾说，咱们把它卖了吧。
就是它其实代表。
这个沈腾黄渤，他们应该是一一个人。
他们代表这个人的每次的两个选择。
正常来说啊，你说一个不挣钱的耍猴人。
就就比如说黄渤儿这个角色，作为一个不挣钱的耍猴人，他的内心难道没有动过气候从商的念头吗？他一定动过。
所以把它外化成。
沈腾这个角色就天天念叨的。
那跟我挣钱跟我挣钱，咱俩卖酒。
其实就是他性格一部分的外化，至于为什么要在戏中把它外化出来呢？为什么？
是为了。
快速的推进剧情，省的角色跟自己打架。
角色自己跟自己打架是一种内心对抗。
这种搞法呢很文艺的。
明白吗？很吃篇幅的。
在商业片中啊，特别是在这种盯光很爽的商业片当中啊。
这种事情呢就就他就不太愿意搞。
他就索性把这个角色拆开。
一目了然。
好吧，呃这种就是他就是假假多主角。
什么叫真多主角的戏啊？
就是戏当中要有明确的篇幅来表现这两个人的互相影响，互相成成就，互相牺牲。
最简单的啊就是你就看这两个人有没有决裂过。
这两个人。
咔嚓真的决裂了。
这种戏。
还是就是他有人物关系了，你懂我意思吧？
他有人物关系了，你疯狂的外星人沈腾、黄冠从头到尾两兄弟一起，对吧？从头到尾那个没头脑和不高兴呀。
这这这这就假假假假多主。好，这是题外话啊，题外话我们后面会说在这儿就是就是大家领会精神来西游记回来啊，回来回来回来，西游记四个人，师徒取经人一个人，好吧。
欲望是什么？
欲望是普渡众生。
出发前讲的嘛。
出发前告别逃王怎么说的？
说哎呀呀呀呀呀这个这个这个这个这个小称佛教呀，佛教什么叫小称啊？
小称佛教就是说啊你读了之后修行，把你自己给给给搞牛逼了。你这是光顾自己啊，小称小称，那说那什么叫大乘呢？大秤就是说你这个佛法可以普渡众生。然后唐僧说我要普渡众生。
对吧然后他就他的欲望是普渡众生。
然后说那普渡钟生咋普呢？
人家告诉他，在这个这个西西方世界，西方极乐世界是有相关文件的。
对吧这个这个这个呃其实他指的就是印度那个佛教的发源地嘛。
然后这个这个所以引发了动作。
就是取经啊。
就是取经。
对吧。
那。
这个故事的核心事件是什么？西游记的核心事事件是什么？
一路向西。
整个故事不就是一路向西吗？
一直在奔西走吗？往西天走嘛？就西天取经嘛，障碍我就不说了吧。九九八十一难，我写我都懒得往上写。
结果是什么呢？
这几个人成佛了，取到经了，而且成佛了。
成佛。
得京成佛。
吃粉饼啊。
来。
这个故事的主题是。
价值是。
真正的修行。
实际上，他们在路上已经经历了。
真正的佛法。
就在他们内心。
最后主题不就是这样吗？
他们的吸钱渠道的经营是假的呀，空的呀，没有用的呀。
对吧而且悟空还说呢，就那我们可以成佛了吗？我们做了这么大多贡献，我们成佛了吗？
关音怎么告诉他们的？那么早就是了呀，你们看看你们自己呀。
成佛普渡众生，不是某个仪式，不是某篇经文。
是你们一路上做的善举，善行，已经普度众生了。
这是主题。
明白吗？
正能量吗？
太他妈挣了，倍儿正啊。
是不是啊？
这太正了。
就你上什么西天取经啊。
你去。
解救百姓就是取经。
就是普渡众生。
不是西天有本经文让你普渡众生。
就是这个这就是西游记的主题，是你一路上去解救的那些人，帮助的那些人。
降妖伏魔做的这些好事儿。
啊，就是普渡众生，这就是西游记的意义主题。
所以我跟我跟大家说，我为什么前面讲到主题的时候，我一直。
这个这个这个欲言又止，欲句欢迎的。
就是因为我们你不体会到这整个故事，你是没有办法理解为什么。
一个故事还需要个主题。
我如果不讲后面单说哎一个故事有三要素，人物事件主题，你听到脑子面就啊，什么人出了什么事儿主题。
对吧有什么好主题的？
这就是主题。
这就是主题明白了吧？
所以你现在看啊。
你要写一个故事。
你把这8个事情从头到尾说一遍。
诶，你就有了。
对吧一个侠客想报仇。
找仇人去。
头人可不好找吧。
小兵挺多。
一路上都跟我干，而且这仇人武艺高强，结果呢我没有杀掉这个仇人，但是我化解了心中的仇恨。
主题就是报酬。其实。
并不一定要杀掉对方。
你只需要化解心中的仇恨。
嗯，主题。
是不是？所以说随便一个怂，这这这最俗最怂的故事都可以搞搞出一个故事。
那你说哦那就是你告诉我们8个元素，我们把它组在一块搞个从故事啊这节课就就这些吗？
当然不是同学们。
这8个东西搞起来是有技巧的。
是有技巧的。
我们下节课再说吧。
好吧。
好。
下课。